this is classic offense versus defense
what I'm really good at is marketing in
the year that we actually live in wait
okay I said jump down baby run down
which is running down lunges you do
lunges let my son down what's found
better what's found let me see that bad
kid elated mad city let's agree that I'm
doing the gusts a light up my focaccia
kanpai
this is about his basic economics as you
really can get into however people don't
understand there is a fundamental reason
why big companies go out of business
because they don't mark it and execute
in the world we live in what they don't
understand is the risk reward the risk
reward let me explain to you well
everybody sits around and says well I
don't want to invest my time or money
into snapchat a year or two ago I'm
jumping in there and trying to figure it
out they wait while everybody else
innovates and executes and takes their
business Blockbuster didn't have the
data to tell them why to buy Netflix for
40 million dollars eight years ago that
put them out of business
you're saying it's risky to put your
time and money into snapchat in case it
disappears
I implore you to start taking these
channels seriously Instagram got 50
million users 50 million users in 1.6
years I say it's risky to not jump in
there in case it explodes 99% of the
people in this room do not mark it in
the year that we actually live in if you
are not in full pledged effort of
storytelling on Facebook Twitter
Pinterest and Instagram at this moment
you are borderline not relevant to
what's about to happen in next 24 months
that's period for example when I was
buying Google AdWords in in 2000 2001
when I bought the word wine for 10 cents
that was a good deal you're talking
about a $14 word right now most people
aren't executing on so many different
variables they can't show the ROI look I
get it you want to show the ROI of your
Instagram campaign and you've got
somebody disciplined above you that
doesn't know how to quantify it and you
walk in and say hey we did really well
this month we got 1,700 hearts that's a
tough thing to sell through
I respect that so the question becomes
while everybody was debating is this
Google AdWords thing really sell is this
a good thing
where are our eyeballs at ears going
that to me is the thing that I'm
completely obsessed with right now where
are we spending our time I'm racking up
the returns on that inexpensive cost
that later turns out to be obvious to
the market when the market becomes aware
and smart about it it dilutes that's
basically the way I think about
marketing which is why in 2007 nobody
even knows what Twitter is and I'm using
a daily engaging with people by the time
people figure out in 2010 11 12 13 that
it matters
I'm amassing my hundreds of thousands of
followers which was easier than so the
game continues to change
this is classic offense versus defense
most of you are on defense I am always
on the offense can I get a minute I'm
let's do a little do you know sign did
you know that in 2006-7
even into eight that it was proper
Twitter etiquette that if somebody
followed you that you followed them back
it doesn't work anymore